"Yes", il en faut très très peu pour être heureux !
Les amis j'ai reçu un e-mail de mon papa, de monsieur Hochard...
Et cet e-mail s'appelle tout simplement
" PHOTOS " *rires*
*rires*
Les amis il y a quatre ans j'avais fait une vidéo qui s'appelait
"Quand j'étais petit et innocent"
Si cette miniature vous dit quelque chose c'est normal,
C'est que Youtube me l'avait ÉNORMÉMENT mis en avant à l'époque
Dans toutes les suggestions
Je crois que Youtube voulait vraiment que les gens savent à quoi je ressemblais
quand j'avais 10 ans.
Mon père a retrouvé une nouvelle série de photos
De son fils préféré
Je suis trop content d'avoir eu un parent qui était fan de photographie quand j'étais plus jeune
Parce que du coup bah j'ai une trace de ces années là.
Et ça m'arrange !
Parce qu'aujourd'hui mon travail c'est faire des vidéos alors
Ça me donne des idées de vidéos
Faciles, finalement !
Merci papa d'avoir pensé à moi
Je suis sûr qu'il a fait dans ce but là en plus !
Aujourd'hui nous allons voir Squeezie pré-ado
Puis Squeezie ado
J'ai jamais trop compris la différence, dans les deux cas t'es moche, t'as des boutons.
C'est parti !
De mes 12 ans à mes 17 ans.
Voyons la gueule que j'avais, let's GO !
Yes !
Ça fait plaisir, on commence sur une photo qui me met extrêmement en valeur
*rires*
Il est vrai qu'à 12 ans
La caractéristique principale était
Cet espace entre chacune de mes dents
Ça contribuait à mon charme de l'époque
Charme qui atteignait... Zéro fille
Oh j'avais un bracelet de tectonique KILLER !
*rires*
C'est si mignon !
À cette époque-là il est vrai, ma musique préférée était...
*musique de tectonique*
Suivant.
Putain mais c'est quoi cet événement j'ai aucun souvenir de cet événement
Tu vois je parlais des trucs qui m'ont marqué
Ça m'a clairement pas marqué
AH !
Le buffalo !
*rires*
Mais personne n'a de souvenirs de quand ils mangent ou buffalo
Ça n'existe pas !
Vous pensez que c'est possible je m'amuse encore plus que là
Sur la photo d'après ?
*rires*
OUI !
C'était peut-être le nouvel an mec
Mais oui on fait pas toujours le nouvel an avec ses amis
Jusqu'à 4 heures du mat'
Desfois on le fait que jusqu'à minuit quatre
Au buffalo
C'est comme ça !
On m'a forcer à aller là
Je discutais avec qui voulait discuter tu vois
Même un cow-boy en polystyrène 'fin
C'est pareil
Ah bah c'est mieux les veuch' là p*tain j'ai changé de coiffeur mec
C'était les 50 ans de mon papa
Juste ici
Et moi c'était mes 12 ans, le jour de mes 12 ans
Et une fois plus je rêvais tout simplement pas d'être ici
Mais de jouer à Dofus BAH OUI on voulait que ça à 12 ans, arrêtez !
J'arrête pas de dire ça mais c'est tellement vrai mec !
Je ne vivais que pour ça.
Vous ne pouvez pas vous rendre compte.
Mec le soir je me couchais.
Il y avait des points de dégâts qui s'affichaient comme ça...
Je me réveillais,
Je croyais que je venais de loot une maîtrise d'armes, alors pas du tout !
J'avais dormi !
Allez suivant !
Oh ! Alors ça c'était...
Désolé ça fait beaucoup de visages floutés mais il y a peut-être des gens qui ont envie de garder leur vie privée
SECRÈTE !
C'était le mariage des filles de ma belle mère
Ah non !
C'était le mariage...
Tout le monde s'en bat les couilles en plus de ça on s'en fout enfin bref c'était un mariage.
*rires*
Je me fais chier pour rien.
Alala Florent !
Oh je suis content, une fois de plus je fais chier mon frère
En l'exposant dans une de mes vidéos ça, ça me fait plaisir !
Il m'en parle à chaque fois !
Florent t'avais un très beau style
C'est toi qui méritait de te marier ce jour-là
Car c'était TOI le plus beau.
*kiss*
Et de l'autre côté de l'image
On a un style un peu plus négatif
Une personne très peu à l'aise dans sa tenue
Qui rêve une fois de plus d'être...
Devant Dofus
Ce qui est fou, c'est que dix ans après j'ai le même problème
Je trouve aucun costume cravate à ma taille
Je pense que de base, ça ne me va pas
Mais qu'en plus ma corpulence fait que ça me va encore moins.
Ah ! Là on est à l'aise
P'tin mec j'avais des cernes
J'avais 12 ans et j'avais des cernes, gros
J'étais en vacances à ce moment là hein, donc c'est pas parce qu'il y avait école ou quoi
C'est juste que je jouais jusqu'à 5 heures du mat'
Et que je me levais à onze heures
Pour re-continuer de jouer.
C'est incroyable !
OOOOOOOOOOH
Je sais pas qui est cet homme à droite de toute manière il est flouté donc vous savez pas non plus !
Le bronzage.
Oh !
" Les petits mecs "
Tiens donc !
Est ce que ça existe encore ?
C'est des costumes pour enfant
Donc c'était un costume pour enfant
Et ça m'allait quand même pas !?
Regardez il fait plus vieux que moi !
Mais attends mec par contre ce qui est stylé c'est que du coup aujourd'hui là maintenant
Bah je sais où acheter un costume qui taillera bien
De 2 à 16 ans
Ben mec je penche j'prends un 15 ans et ça me va
Non mais vraiment
Oh mec !
J'ai envie d'en commander un !
Mec j'suis en train de le commander
Non mais vraiment !
Je veux savoir
Si un costume destiné un enfant de 16 ans me va
OK mec c'est commandé
J'ai acheté un costume destiné à un enfant de 16 ans voilà, juste pour voir
Cherchez pas.
La suite maintenant !
Laissez-moi oublier ça
Oooooooh
Le mépris
Sur ce visage
*rires*
Et Florent là !
C'est pas parce que t'as un style de mannequin en L que tu peux me regarder comme ça
Calme toi
Qu'est-ce que tu fais là ?
Si t'étais jaloux parce que j'avais une pano bouftou et pas toi
Bah fallait me demander de te la prêter
*rires*
Ça je me souviens très bien
C'est le jour mon frère j'crois il avait... En 2012
Mon frère avait...
22 ans ?
22 ans ?!
Attends c'est-à-dire que là, il avait l'âge que j'ai maintenant
Et regardez il a très peu de barbe
Ça veut dire gros dans quatre ans j'aurais sa bebar de maintenant, peut-être !?
P*TAAAAIIIIN !!!
Bref à 22 ans, mon frère reçoit son PREMIER ordinateur
Un ordi portable
Et moi en voyant ça
Qu'est ce que je me dis ?
Je me dis :
" P*tain le FDP "
" Il va pouvoir faire de l'ordi quand il veut "
" Parce qu'il va avoir ÇA dans sa chambre "
J'étais trop jaloux.
Sauf que moi contrairement à mon frère qui me juge, qu'est ce que je fais ?
PETIT regard amical,
Montrant ma bienveillance envers ce dernier.
C'est TOUT !
AH ! Tiens !
Le regard amical se transforme en
Visage de la jalousie !
*rires*
" UN SEUM COLOSSAL "
Et en vrai c'est cool qu'il ait eu un ordi parce qu'il commençait je crois déjà à...
Il avait acheté une tablette graphique qui est relié à son ordi pour commencer déjà à dessiner et tout
Donc en vrai ça l'a aidé puisque aujourd'hui c'est son métier, il vit de ça
Donc très bon moove de la part de mon père de lui offrir ça.
OOOOOOOH YES !
C'est cette photo là !
J'ai survolé vite fait toutes les photos
Quand je les ai reçu de mon papa, pour voir si c'était pas les mêmes déjà qu'il y a quatre ans
Je suis tombé sur ÇA
Du coup je l'ai direct mis sur Instagram
Suivez-moi sur Instagram @xsqueezie
Je vous le répète suivez-moi sur Instagram @xsqueezie
Et c'est devenu LA photo
L'une des photos les plus likée de mon compte
Et celle qui a atteint je crois le plus de gens
Enfin bref c'est... Les gens ont été ému
Donc je pense que je n'étais pas seul !
À mettre des tongues et à jouer à Dofus à cette époque-là !
Par contre j'étais le seul à avoir
Ni un casque ou des écouteurs, mais avoir un casque-outeur
C'est nul à chier, n'achetez jamais ça.
Je jouais mon petit Feca,
Les connaisseurs reconnaîtront la map...
'Au Zaap d'Astrub la map du dessus'
C'est là où il y avait tous les défis hein !
C'est là où on kikait des culs !
Et en fait je regardais des mecs se battre.
Regardez là, je regarde la vidéo d'un mec
Je sais pas , p'tin ce serait trop drôle de retrouver la vidéo que j'avais regardé
" Dofus -Evil-Sadida VS Perco "
Est ce que je vais regarder cette vidéo dix ans après ?!
*rires*
...
Il y a rien qui va
Rien ne va !
Bon en tout cas
Je rêvais d'être -Evil-Sadida
-Evil-Sadida si tu regardes cette vidéo
*kiss*
Tu m'as envoyé de l'amour quand j'étais jeune, quand j'en n'avais besoin
J'espère que tu vas bien toi et ta famille puisque t'as sûrement une famille à l'heure actuelle
À moins que t'aies jamais décroché de Dofus
OoOoOoOoOh
Bah regardez, dès qu'il y a plus Dofus
Alors il est où le petit sourire hein !
Oh mec comment je me fais chier !
En fait faut se rendre compte que j'étais vraiment
EXTRÊMEMENT
Addict aux jeux vidéos.
Et même jusqu'à peu en vrai, jusqu'à il y a un an là, j'étais HYPER addict
Et là je me suis vraiment calmé
Et ça me fait du bien, vraiment
Mais du coup à l'époque dès que j'étais pas devant un écran
J'avais cette gueule quoi.
C'est grave !
OH ! Bah attends
Il y avait Carlito à mes repas de famille ?
Le pull un peu tectonique
Mec j'étais vraiment un tectonique hein, ça je vous le jure
Les damiers, les trucs et tout, on se souvient
C'était un peu tectonique hein, vraiment l'époque c'était ça
C'est mes 13 ans
Un an sont passé et comme vous l'avez vu
Les seules photos que mon père a pris
C'est trois photos de moi devant Dofus
Il y avait un seul moment où j'étais pas devant Dofus et je faisais la gueule.
Alala, regardez les premiers boutons apparaissent
P'tin j'ai l'air FATIGUÉ mec c'est un truc de ouf
En fait aujourd'hui je trouve que j'ai l'air tout le temps fatigué
Mais à l'époque mec c'était...
C'était beaucoup plus abusé hein vraiment !
C'est grave à 13 ans d'avoir l'air aussi fatigué
Par contre ce qui est impressionnant aussi c'est que j'ai 13 ans on dirait que j'ai 10
Est-ce que c'est bon ?
OOOOOOH
Bah ça, ça va partir en photo de profil ça !
Heh je vous jure que si mon père m'a envoyé cette photo à l'époque
Je l'aurais mis en photo de profil facebook
Bah je me trouve stylé !
même dix ans après je me trouve beau là dessus les gars
Bah ouais !
Alors... Ah bah là ! Ah bah regarde...
Les choses ne sont pas par hasard
Dix ans après ça, je faisais une vidéo avec le rédacteur en chef du petit Larousse
C'est pas beau ça !
Mais là j'en avais aucune idée là, à ce moment là
Je pensais à mon bécaf libre ! Regardez ma gueule !
Regarde mec comme je suis perdu
Putain on dirait un mec paumé, vraiment
J'ai vraiment l'air fatigué, mais regarde !
Mais c'est pas grave si t'as pas la puissance de - Evil-Sadida, Lucas
C'est pas grave !
Pense à autre chose !
Oh là là... Oh ! Ça y est j'ai changé de moule là,
Ça doit être deux ans plus tard là.
Il y a un truc qui a changé.
Ah le... Pas le buffalo ! Le buffalo est toujours là, rassurez-vous.
Surtout regardez... L'acné commence à arriver.
Ah oui oui oui ! Mais Lucas tu es loin de t'imaginer à quel point elle va être présente dans ta vie.
Tu sais pas !
...
Bon.
J'avais fait cette photo à l'époque
Parce que je savais que tôt ou tard un jour j'allais parler d'acné dans ma vie.
Regardez l'acné qui arrive...
La peau de plus en plus rouge,
Les boutons de plus en plus grands,
Et ça me complexait beaucoup beaucoup comme tous les gens qui ont beaucoup beaucoup de boutons
Mais sachez que tôt ou tard
Ils disparaîtront ces putains de boutons.
Oh non, je me cache...
Non vraiment, vraiment j'étais pas bien je vous jure...
Déjà je crois je m'endormais donc c'est confortable
Mais aussi j'avais un peu honte de l'acné et tout.
Oh là là, je fais que de me cacher
Je crois qu'en fait du coup les photos, j'avais du mal
Parce qu'après quand je les voyais j'avais trop d'acné ça me faisait mal.
Ah ça me fait bizarre, c'est triste
C'est triste, ça commençait vraiment à me complexer énormément quoi.
Et encore là ça se voit pas trop mais... Voilà.
Il y a du bouton quoi.
Un peu partout.
Nous sommes les frères Looser
*rires*
Oui le chat de mon papa
Toujours en vie à l'heure actuelle
P'tin il est vieux !
Il doit avoir 11-12 ans du coup à l'heure actuelle
C'est ouf !
Oh là là, mais il se passe quoi là ?
Eh les gars vous avez avait tout pour être heureux
C'est le dimanche matin qu'est-ce qu'il vous arrive
P'tin mais j'ai fais une teinture ou quoi mec
J'ai les cheveux noirs, c'est incroyable !
Alors c'est quoi ? Qu'est-ce que j'ai eu ?
Attends...
Un truc d'énigmes !
*rires*
Pas mal ! En vrai c'est bien !
En gros le but de ma famille, c'était de m'offrir des cadeaux
Qui me fassent sortir des écrans...
Voilà.
Genre un truc d'énigme ils se sont dit :
" Oh, c'est un peu proche des jeux, des énigmes... Huh "
" Il sortira de ses écrans "
Et bah nan !
Moi ce que je veux c'est un abonnement d'un an à DOFUS !
" BANDE DE SAL*PES "
Oh oui !
Magnifique !
Mon set-up gaming.
Pendant trois ans chez mon père, c'était ça mec
C'était sur ce PC que je montais mes vidéos
Avec ce clavier et cette souris
Je dormais, je me levais, je jouais
Et là je venais de recevoir ma première carte d'acquisition
Pour pouvoir enregistrer du gameplay de console en fait.
Donc c'est mon père m'avait offert ça,
Il m'avait aussi offert ma première caméra HD hein, on s'en souvient !
Du coup là, voilà
j'étais en train de l'installer
Fallait la mettre dans le PC...
Ah nan ! Je me trompe !
C'est une carte graphique c'est pas une carte d'acquisition !
Je jouais au jeu en putain de grosse qualité à Battlefield et tout, c'était génial.
Et je crois le noël d'après du coup, j'ai reçu la carte d'acquisition
qui me permettait d'enregistrer du gameplay console en HD et tout
J'étais trop content.
Tu vois tout ça, tout ce qu'on est en train de voir, là
C'est grâce à cet homme, mon pote !
Il est là, le Hochart avec son appareil à la main !
Cette vidéo...
*kiss*
Les revenus lui seront versés !
*rires*
Ah bah tiens !
Ça y est Lucas il a 14-15 ans, il se sent pousser des ailes, il tape une petite bière !
L'abus d'alcool est dangereux pour le santé je le rappelle
Il faut être majeur pour boire, merci.
OOOooohh
Mon deuxième set-up !
Le PC que j'avais du coup, je l'avais donné à mon père, c'était celui-là,
Et moi avec la Youtube money,
Je m'étais acheté une tour gaming
Pour pouvoir faire mes montages avec une fluidité maximale
Et enregistrer les jeux en Mega Mega HD,
Et j'avais aussi ma petite Xbox, là c'était ma période Call Of Duty !
Ça y est, on était sorti de Dofus
J'entrais dans le Call Of Game !
Du coup quand j'allais un week-end sur deux chez mon père, bah je posais ma tour dans son bureau,
Je branchais l'écran et tout et puis je...
Je...
J'ai...
Bah voilà !
il était exclu son bureau finalement.
Bah là, là vous connaissez hein
Là j'ai la gueule que j'ai dans les... Dans plein de vidéos en fait.
Dans les vidéos, je crois que ça c'est la gueule que j'avais quand je faisais des podcasts il me semble à un moment...
Et je me retrouve à prendre la place de mon père, et à moi, faire des images de tout le monde,
Pour que eux peut-être des années plus tard fassent une vidéo où ils regardent ces images.
*rires*
Le cycle suit son cours :
C'est magnifique !
Les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo !
J'espère que vous vous serez pas trop embêté,
J'espère que ça vous a plu,
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si c'est le cas !
C'est marrant comme on a des souvenirs de ces époques-là,
Mais en fait c'est assez flou
Et c'est en voyant les photos et les vidéos qu'on arrive vraiment à se souvenir en détail de ce qu'on ressentait
À ce moment là, en fait.
Je sais que j'ai commencé à être beaucoup plus heureux,
Et à savoir un peu plus où je vais quand j'ai commencé à faire des vidéos en fait,
Même au tout début
Même quand ça faisait 200 vues,
Parce que j'avais trouvé LE truc qui me plaisait
Et LE truc dans lequel m'investir.
Même si j'étais hyper loin de
De me douter de... Que la suite, ça allait être bah...
Là où je suis maintenant en fait !
Donc vraiment merci parce que...
Vous vous rendez pas compte mais ça m'a vraiment fait beaucoup beaucoup de bien
À cette époque et je m'en rends encore plus compte en voyant les images,
Et ça me faisait vraiment plaisir voilà donc merci beaucoup pour ça.
Je vous fais plein de TRÈS gros bisous
Je vous dis à très dans une prochaine vidéo et attends !
Est-ce que j'ai reçu le costume ?
Est-ce que je l'ai reçu...?
J'espère !
Si oui bah il y a le moment maintenant, sinon il y a l'outro
Voilà, je vous aime.
...
*Rires*
Je rentre dedans !
Il est un peu petit, genre si je fais ça, je le craque...
Mais mec je rentre dedans !
Il me va mieux que tout ceux que j'ai essayé de ma vie !
Mec, pour mon mariage
Il faudra que je commande mon costume sur un site qui s'appelle
" Les petits mecs "
Sur un site dont juste le nom me rappelle mon problème de corps de lâche
AAAAAAAAH !
J'AI LE SEUM !